welcome eggs benedict I'm not benedict
cumberbatch i'm me i'm marga blyer why
do I want Dancy pants to be mad at me
foxy is a big old bag of dicks
the other options press for numbers I
can't put any numbers in here hey baby
baby come out baby come back oh God Oh
crying guys I'm trying
shut the [ __ ] up
oh hey how did I let up started
everything okay what do I do
no no no no no no none Laura no no no no
no no none kill me no no no no none
digging you need to worry about me I
just need to worry about me
and don't mind the yelling oh yeah what
I'm nervous we did it we're the best in
the world in we your friends for Oh ever
okay these casual bongos of turned sour
there is no need to check on baby
tonight please refrain from entering
unauthorized areas proceed directly to
funtime auditorium you have been
provided with a flash beacon I got boned
oh who is it a pineapple under the sea
what
why is below looking at me wines below
looking at me why did I will chill
damnit oh hi who the [ __ ] is that what
the [ __ ] are you
I'll look at you in just a second the
holy [ __ ]
I'm Farber Nook time fob or Duncan fob
or nook Hey oh wait wagging
I was wobble dabbling wowie Zowie who P
paui [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh yes yes yes
whose day minute [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah yes
yes so long damn work on attention I get
to keep my glorious crown and continue
to call myself the king of five nights
at freddys isn't sorry did I not say
that right look King how so what what
wait hi baby
I didn't you enjoying my body you get
out here no way no no no not happening
nope nothing that's no that's a big no
fudge fudge fudge fudge fudge fudge
fudge there is no way that that is going
to work it is a load of [ __ ] and I
hate it a lot
oh no no no no I want to quit now oh no
supposed to go back to the beginning all
right look it's a two star it's a two
star no that's a forester it's a two
star two for victory however the [ __ ]
that understand it oh god is baby on the
way babies on the way oh [ __ ] this is
five nights at baby's I'm not gonna make
it
Hey hi you get really skedaddle II at
four am ha don't you I did it I am no
man oh got light at it oh I got my
exotic butters yes and I buttered my
popcorn from all around the world but I
did it
place the crown upon my head ow and then
call me the gang of five so I don't
think there's anything new exotic
butters exotic butters exile exotic
butters how long until someone makes a
remix of exotic butters
[Applause]
my foot
damn the job
I forget which one
first those burgers
[Music]